ce rapport sur le parlementarisme et la
citoyenneté européenne est cruciale à la
veille des élections européennes il
rappelle que ce Parlement est le cœur de
la démocratie européenne il rappelle que
nous députés européens représentant les
citoyens directement
mais les citoyens le savent-ils comment
leur donnons-nous les moyens de résister
à la désinformation nationaleiste au
discours qui attaque l'Union européenne
pourtant si protectrice au travers de
chaque crise la solution est dans ce
rapport c'est l'éducation civique
européenne c'est une nécessité comment
savoir qu'on est citoyens européens qui
en connais pas le fonctionnement de
l'Union européenne ni ses valeurs
fondamentales
l'éducation civique européenne les
citoyens nous lendemain d'ailleurs
demandé directement lors de la
conférence pour l'avenir de l'Europe
mais pour que chacun puisse accéder à
minimum d'éducation civique européenne
dans chaque État membre cela appelle à
plus de compétences partagées en matière
d'éducation et c'est là encore un
objectif de ce rapport aller plus loin
avec une réformes institutionnelle
incluant la réouverture des traités pour
une Europe encore plus efficace pour
nous concitoyens merci beaucoup